ce matin dans les rues de planoise pas
l'ombre d'un uniforme logique l'économie
souterraine n'embauchent pas à l'heure
des honnêtes citoyens
ces derniers sont d'ailleurs assez
partagés quant à l'arrivée de nouveaux
renforts crs dans le quartier et après
photo c'est déjà la présence policière
c'est déjà quelque chose de très très
bien les jeunes d'ici paris 108
personnes sans logis ont occupé
moi ça fait 30 ans que j'habite ici j'ai
jamais rien vu de concret ici rien si
une fois comme hysteria 500000 euros
ça fait maintenant un compte twitter
mais on a deux familles déchirées
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire un dix sept ans quand
vient d'enterrer et bien 24 ans qui ces
deux familles déchirées
l'enquète a été bouclé en un temps
record en moins de trois jours l'auteur
présumé du tir mortel a été mise en
examen pour assassinat et écroué
un deuxième homme mis en examen pour
complicité a été placé sous contrôle
judiciaire
enfin le conducteur de l'équipe est
mortel et un troisième passager ont été
mises hors de cause
quant au mobile un différend a priori
personnel il reste à éclaircir
mais en l'état actuel des choses rien ne
permet de le rapprocher du déchaînement
de violences sur fond de guerre des
gangs qui avaient endeuillé le quartier
entre novembre et mars le fait notamment
que le conducteur du véhicule qui
transportait le tireur présumé ce n'est
pas pris la fuite après le coup de feu
soit même venu pour tenter de sauver la
victime est attendu l'arrivée des forces
de l'ordre émis son véhicule à
disposition pour que des constatations
de police technique soit fait à
l'intérieur montre qu'on n'est pas du
tout dans la même logique des équipes
organisées qui vont de façon très
prémédité tiré sur une place delille
tiré en direction de personnes ciblées
pour aussitôt collectivement le
conducteur comme les tireurs s'enfuir en
pleine campagne électorale l'enjeu
sécuritaire fait un retour en force mais
justice et forces de l'ordre sont
formels plus que des renforts policiers
désormais régulier c'est un profond
travail de terrain qui commence à payer